do you feel like um being young you I
mean you kind of are getting like a head
start on a lot of people in terms of
kind of going through like music
industry [__] before you're 18 you uh
you just signed with uh a good friend
brother Uncle of mine Steve Lobel yes
you're the first artist on Lobel music
group yes I am which is in conjunction
with uh Def Jam so shout out to Steve
yeah big deal did you know who Steve
Lobel was like like you like how long
have you known about Steve how long have
I known about him
what
since a little bit before I met him so
when you met him or did it did because
you know lobel's a lot yeah like he hit
you no I've known about like he hit you
with that aggressive Lobel energy no
I've known about his history like
um and the people he's worked with for
sure so yeah because he told you any
cool Bone Thugs-N-Harmony stories yet
yeah he showed me the picture yeah he's
got a lot of have you been to his house
yet no he's he I don't know if he still
has the purple couches you might be able
to tell me he's got these purple couches
at his house they're crazy
um but yeah what what for you like
because you have a huge social media
follower got over a million followers
how did you amass that following just
through music or were you going viral on
Tick Tock or
um I think it was just from me being
like a kid star and everybody like
followed me because I first went viral
on YouTube for like my first two songs
that I put out seriously and they're
over like 70 million views now
um so I feel like that's what people
know me from and then I grew up and
they're like oh where's Brooklyn they
follow me and then I feel like people
just like me because of the stuff I post
damn 70 million views how old were you
when when that happened uh 12. Jesus
yeah shout out to you thank you that
sounds like a gold plaque or something
close right that might be that might be
our like did you put that out through
like this like distribution services
yeah
that sounds like you might you might
need to get a little certification 70
million views is a lot yeah
um has there been anybody on the music
side that is kind of like uh you know
been a mentor for you or somebody who's
giving you advice somebody who's you
know maybe just kind of taking a liken
to you and giving you some free game
um
probably the owner of BNB
partnership with lmg don't play with
this
um yeah probably peanut he's the owner
of the label
I've I would say he's yeah him
that's what I feel
do you you know what's crazy is like
there's another girl who's kind of had a
similar come up a lotto was like a she
kind of was like a kid star yeah and we
see all these videos of her like doing
challenge shows and [__] like have you
like kind of taken any notes and kind of
just from afar watch what she's doing
because she's kind of done a really good
job of like successfully transitioning
yeah from being a kid and then like
being an adult artist that we respect as
an emcee and yeah I feel like that's
what that's how I can kind of relate to
her and that's what I look at her for
like she was such
she's on the rap game and she was like
this kid
um and it was hard for her to go into
the adult Lane when she was getting
older right and I feel like that's the
situation I'm I'm in now I'm trying to
everybody's looking at me as like I'm
just this little girl I'm gonna be 18
y'all let me merge over into being you
know in the teens getting older you
could join the military now uh yeah
how about that what else can you do at
18 you can buy cigarettes no you can't
oh they changed the law actually and you
used to be able to buy Michigan yeah you
used to be able to buy like
I've never smoked so I don't I yeah I
just as a kid it was like okay I'm 18 I
can go to the porno store and I can go
to the damn liquor store and I can get
cigarettes yeah no they changed a lot I
bought cigarettes on my 18th birthday
just to buy them I gave them to my dad
okay he smoked I'm like look I can go to
the store now and buy you cigarettes
look at this isn't this nice you don't
have to get your ass up and go to the
store now and go for you right
um for you like uh
how are you constructing like are you
working on Singles body of work an album
like what are you working on right now
um
um singles okay and if we decide to
album then that's what's gonna happen
but lately I've just been dropping
singles that's dope uh any features in
the works
um in the works of course I just did a
song with very vanilla you know yeah
from Detroit I just did a song with Bae
um I have a song with Yanni she's over
there on the couch shout out to be
Johnny on the couch
um we make songs together and we made a
song called receipts and it did a
million views in a week wow YouTube
stuff yeah well now you got Mr Steve in
your corner he's going he's gonna pick
up that phone you're gonna get some big
features yeah let's do it I'm right here
for sure you got to work with Scott
Storch now okay have you met Scott
Storage yet no very talented guy he's a
uh oh you know who Scott Storch is yeah
yeah one of the greatest producers of
all time